ladies i'm so excited i want to dive
deep right off the bat
and get into it we're going to play a
little game this is a game called to
tell the truth
wow that's good um okay renee you're up
first um
okay when you were in hamilton what
would you and lin-manuel miranda
say in sort of like the huddle before
you would go on the prayer circle before
hamilton
he used to say two things one that i
loved was
it's like a restaurant we're chefs you
know it doesn't matter what the reviews
are those people out there
if the meal isn't good it's not good and
the second thing he would say which i
just moved me so much was whatever you
do
we're proud of you oh isn't that
beautiful
whatever you do out there i'm already
proud of you
that's like what a good parent i was
just gonna say that's a good parenting
is that what a good parent says we're
going to talk about
that too okay paula you were a legendary
writer on saturday night live
i was lucky enough to get to be there in
the years uh that you were there as well
you don't have to tell us who
but was there like a biggest tantrum
that you ever
saw backstage at snl there the biggest
tantrum i
saw was actually for one of our
anniversary shows
i remember someone getting so mad that
rehearsal was taking so long
and they stormed down the hall out of 8h
storming stomping with a couple people
nervously behind them and like you know
and so and because they were missing a
broadway show
and they kept going thanks a lot nbc
thanks a lot and snl and they were in
such a tantrum i mean everyone was
looking at him storming out him
i'm gonna figure it out
he just stormed out and slammed any door
he could and everything and everyone
kind of went
all right like you did not throw a fit
and scream it but you just didn't do it
well that is the oddest parlay into my
question for sarah
because i was wondering you know
you're starring on broadway you do these
huge concerts you have to be live
up front show up um have you ever
had just something happening in your
personal life a physical discomfort
what do you do you want to know what
happens if i have to fart that's what's
happening
or like you just broke up with someone
like farting and a heartbreak
what do you do you know i think in terms
of the emotional stuff you try to
there's just not a world in which you
can't bring it with you somehow and i
think
in the best case scenario you can sort
of fold that into the performance in
some way that feels authentic
um now i think it was written folded in
to the performance um
things happen you know you spent a lot
of time on that stage i
love it okay busy what did you guys talk
about
in the car in that iconic scene that was
literally
not only like i feel like it was on
commercials
for like three years like this scene was
because you're stuck in those cars for a
long time yeah we were
like hours and days so any juicy
gossip fun tidbits from the famous
iconic scene
well mostly this is true
mostly when they said cut uh
sean and marlon were asking us
the lyrics to a thousand miles
and we were asking them
the lyrics to the rap song and to help
us learn
that except for jennifer carpenter who
came
she's in the car with us and she came
and knew
the entire song that's what happens when
you're prepared yes she was prepared get
more screen time get more screen time
yes um now paula i want to ask you
you met your wife on twitter and i loved
it
because it gives it's so hopeful
like how did you guys meet what was it
about that tweet
that changed the rest of your life maybe
you didn't know it then but like oh my
god this is so hopeful i'm so excited
i'm gonna do a very fast version of this
because it is a great
a great thing the way we found each
other is she followed me on twitter i
followed her back i always thought she
was cute but i thought she was way
younger than she is so sorry janine
but uh she's like thanks a lot i just
would always see her on there and she'd
have funny tweets and i'd you know we'd
kind of every so often make a little
comment on each other's stuff
and then one day i was deeply deeply
severely depressed
for a couple years after divorce and i i
told my dog sitter come over i'm gonna
go to
joshua tree with my all my self-help
books
and wine and my crystals i'm gonna go be
by myself and ask the sky and ask
whoever's up there to please guide me
because i am lost and i am
deeply dark and so i went and i
just checked my internet like one time
while i was there and i
see this tweet she put up that said i
was so depressed i went
to an airbnb and i went to joshua tree
and so we started we knew we weren't
going to see each other because she was
there to meet with somebody
um for a work thing for one of the days
and so i
we just like did that thing oh
look at this do you have the same sunset
view right now when we were like sending
pictures and she's like oh this is a dog
i just saw and it was you know
typical hot lesbian fare
and i was i was just like you know and
we just kept talking and talking
and then we had a date the next week and
then we're married now four years
we've been together four years and we
just got married
that's all i wanted i don't even have a
girlfriend
and she's on our show yeah she's on our
show and she plays by my
ex-wife on girls5eva
[Music]